what is the best Bruce Springsteen song
ever written in your opinion I still
think jungle land is one of the most I I
put it up there with like Bohemian
Rhapsody as one of the most impressive
piano parts like this part here
it evokes emotion right away
[Music]
foreign
that slows down Gary
um
I can't I will never sing that song
because I just won't ever be able to do
it justice what is the best Billy Joel
song ever written maybe not the best one
ever but the one he wrote for his
daughter good night my angel turn to
close your eyes
and say these questions for another day
I think maybe or
she takes care of herself
I think that's a really powerful message
about the power of a a really strong
woman too and it's really hard to write
songs like that and make them sound like
uh not reachy and he just does it
effortlessly there and from a penis
point of view Elton John's greatest song
it's a tie between Tiny Dancer
I think the world's answer is going to
be Tiny Dancer my answer is
[Music]
how he ends it too with George Michael
it's just oh it's so British and what
yeah exactly it's cinematic it's like
the end of a movie why do you consider
George Michael such an influence what is
the song that gets you when he was
trying to prove that he wasn't cheesy
from after the success of Wake Me Up
Before You Go-Go kind of reminds me of
like how I was trying to escape my
cheese from CU again because you had a
song in C major which is the cheesiest
of all keys wake me up before you go go
it's a great song
but honest I believe the Same album he
did
oh
[Music]
written and self-produced and on drum
machines he didn't have Pro Tools back
then and James Taylor you mentioned too
is one of your influences what is the
song that you think is the most
brilliant James Taylor song I think on
mudslide slim and Blue Horizon there's a
song called long growing far away
[Music]
but things are not the same it seems oh
my God I got I gave myself chills right
now but things are not the same it seems
is in such tender dreams and he went to
where do you golden
rainbows and Joni's singing in the
background
why is this song so sad
dream in the dreams I've dreamed my
friend
loving the love I love to love is just a
word I've heard just hauntingly
beautiful are you blown away like I am
when you hear stories about Neil Young
he saw the what happened to Kent State
in Ohio and he goes into the woods and
in 20 minutes walks out with that song
Ohio 20 minutes oh it's there oh he's
something I mean are you into him oh man
look at my life
I'm alive like you were oh my goodness
like how those are again those are two
chords
Beyond how do you play play it on an
actual guitar yeah
[Music]
oh it just repeats it oh
my goodness
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I wasn't around obviously but I take
note of it in the 70s it was just
everyone was going through something it
was like and everyone used this
[Music]
like this
it's the Accord musical equivalent of
putting your fingers on your chin and
rubbing it and thinking where am I going
to be in the 80s
foreign